[Music]
Invercargill City Council's greenly
brands have come up with a list of a
hundred and one things to do in and
around Invercargill that are either free
or low-cost here are five of my family
favorites number seven
Earthcare Park is one of them became was
beeps keep secrets
this is idyllic Park which is good
against the famous spectra of the
invocation water tower number 64
dandy point provides current activities
and is an outstanding natural playground
visit whaler's bay and see the remains
from early settlers to the region number
79
beachcombers cottage near Greenfield is
an eclectic one blinkered all of the
unique sculptures on this plane are made
from items they've been beachcombers
locally number 37 Elizabeth Park is
located off John Street and also in Vine
Street it provides a large welcoming
open space with a playground BMX track
and walking trip number 70 strange take
a look at the bluff Maritime Museum and
Explorer bus incredible history while
you're the airclimber border monitor a
full order boat so there you have it
to find your favorites download the
pocket-sized guide and I simply just
services our Indian employ your council